نعم خالد مرحله متقدمه وصل لها مشروع
حدائق الملك عبد الله العالميه هذا
المشروع الضخم الذي بدا العقد التنفيذي له
في عام 2019 عندما عملت امانه منطقه
الرياض على مواءمه هذا المشروع مع
مستهدفات رؤيه 2030 سياحيا وبيئيا
واقتصاديا وايضا حتى ترفيهيا من خلال هذا
المشروع متبقي يعني اكثر من النصف قليلا
او اقل ايضا نسبه الانجاز تجاوزت الاربعين
بالمئه اعمال البنى التحتيه توشك على
الانتهاء لانشاءات مستمره حقيقه المشروع
يسير بوتيره سريعه في هذه الاوقات هو اقف
الان انا امام مبنى الهلالين وهو واحد من
المباني الرئيسيه او العناصر المهمه في
المشروع والذي يضم سبع حدائق تمثل الحقب
التاريخيه القديمه
في العالم بالاضافه الى العديد من المواقع
الاخرى من خلف الان حديقه الوادي الممتده
على مساحه 100000 متر مربع وهي تمثل
الثروه البيئيه للسعوديه وتركز على ذلك
العديد من المواقع والمنشات الاخرى في
المشروع مثل الحدائق الخارجيه التي تركز
على التعليم تفاصيل اكثر معي الان مدير
المشروع المهندس ناصر الوادعي اهلا وسهلا
مهندس ناصر في البدايه 40% نسبه متقدمه
تجاوز طموها في هذا المشروع ما هي تفاصيل
الانجازات التي تمت خلال الفتره الماضيه
بحمد الله وتوفيقه ودعمنا للقياده الرشيده
ومتابعه من القيادات بامانه منطقه الرياض
وعلى راسهم
امين منطقه الرياض الحمد لله تجاوزت نسبه
الاعمال الاربعين في المئه نستطيع ان نلخص
المحاور الانجاز في ثلاثه محاور المحور
الرئيسي مبنى الهلالين والمتحف النباتي تم
انجاز معظم
الخرسانيه واعمال العزل واعمال الهيكل
المعدني بالاضافه الى التغطيه الخاصه بهذا
المبنى
كما تم الانجاز الاعمال الشبكات البنيه
التحتيه للري
والتصريف المحور الاخر البنيه التحتيه
للموقع العام لخدمات المسانده الحمد لله
تم انجاز نسبه كبيره من الاعمال الشبكات
الميكانيكيه بما فيها تصريف مياه الامطار
شبكات الري المعالجه مياه الشرب بالاضافه
الى الشبكات الجهد المتوسط والجهد المنخفض
المحور الاخير الحدائق كما تفضلتم الحدائق
الخارجيه وهي تتمثل في حدائق الطيور
والفراشات الاكتشاف الصوت والضوء معظم
الاعمال في هذه الحدائق الاساسيه انتهت
بما فيها الشبكات والجاسات الحجريه
المتبقي ان شاء الله اعمال التشطيبات خلال
الفتره القادمه مهندس ناصر يعني لاحظنا في
المشروع في تفاصيل المشروع بالاضافه الى
التركيز على السياحه والترفيه وايضا
الثقافه وغيرها هناك تركيز مهم على قطاع
التعليم كيف سيضيف هذا المشروع الى قطاع
التعليم من خلال المنظومه التعليميه في
السعوديه طبعا حنا نستهدف في المشروع ان
يكون به جاذبه
التعليم على مستويه المستوى الاول المستوى
البحث العلمي والتعليم العالي الاستفاده
من الاصول اللي موجوده سواء بتنوع
النباتات اكثر من 1400 نوع من النباتات
بامكان الاجراءات والابحاث العلميه
بالاضافه الى التعليم العام وعمل الزيارات
الميدانيه للطلاب والمدارس لنشر الوعي في
المحافظه على البيئه والمحافظه على ثروه
الطبيعيه البيئيه المملكه داخل مبنى
الهلاليين يوجد سبع حدائق او متحف ان
استطعنا القول بانه هذا المتحف يختلف عن
بقيه المتاحف النباتيه في دول العالم كيف
ذلك صحيح المتحف
تم تصميمه بشكل مختلف عن المتاحف النباتيه
الموجوده حول العالم بحيث يحكي قصه
النباتات من مختلف الحقب التاريخيه فيها
النبات ابتداء من العصر الديفوني وصولا
الى العصر الحديث جميع
المتاحف الموجوده تم تاصيله الى النباتات
بشكل علمي يمكن طبعا للزائر الانتقال فيها
بشكل سلس
بوجود بعض الانظمه والاجهزه التي تشكل
الطقس والبيئه التي عاشت فيها النباتات في
تلك الحقبه كل الشكر لك مهندس ناصر اذا في
هذا المشروع الذي سيكون معلم مهم من معالم
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وهو يقع بالقرب
من مشروع الجديه احدى اكبر واهم المشاريع
الترفيهيه والرياضيه في السعوديه وهو تابع
لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه سيكون هذا
المشروع مهم وايضا
معززا للاقتصاد السعودي والسياحه في
السعوديه ضمن خطط رؤيه 2030